[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have Josh what's up yeah come
to the show Josh continued a long time
buddy couldn't see a while it's been a
while dude the last time you were single
where I was we're engaged
yeah actually I've met you Allison Oh
engaged and single is the same framing
David yeah your place I was with Nicki
but we were dating we're just trying to
y'all know each other your light to
intermediate [ __ ] yeah I think we just
met your David right I met you through
David Alvarez yeah yeah you came to our
place magician on clothes yeah he's
pretty magical David Alvarez yeah yeah
he's not the magician that this is is he
was just on my podcast Oh was it really
yeah because they weren't buds for a
little bit yeah we had a falling out we
had a falling out ah we live together
and then there was just like some drama
in the household household and then it
just kind of split us apart you know I
[Laughter]
think we could be good roommates up yeah
we'd be great thank you I can't have any
roommates anymore yeah I like it yeah
yeah holder you know 29 okay yeah okay
ginger how the [ __ ] did you guys meet
David our friend through our friend
Dennis yeah like a VidCon or something
like that maybe some like that yeah yeah
and I remember your ex are you so what
the chick
uh yeah ex yeah yeah she was really cool
I liked her a lot I proved cool what do
you do not man yeah just hanging out man
just creating content online I'm trying
to like focus more like acting hosting
stuff I had a show that came on Netflix
called cooking on how I that was that I
remember that you know you get high no I
don't what the title of the show yeah
yeah I was like I want him to be high
and I'm like he's not high oh dude at
all yeah it was this yes I named it so
it's a competitive cannabis cooking show
they have like chefs that are gourmet
chefs that specialize in cooking with we
decide like that and they have
celebrities that come on judge the food
and get high and then they judge it once
i snooped
the high expertise were like 80 year old
grandmas no leverage were like not
celebrities yeah exactly white anybody
Betty White's the celebrity oh that's
why the biggest I guess that was
probably Maude son he was dating a bella
thorne at one point but that was like I
don't even know he's a rapper he's a so
he got a residual Fame from bella thorne
basically about yeah before we shot the
show he wasn't dating her and then once
they started dating he like took off
that's like run off the show a little
bit familiar with what I call YouTube
run off
we're like a guy is dating a very famous
YouTube person and because of the famous
YouTube person or vice versa to check
the chickens famous order are the he's
famous and she's not famous but then
they become like social media people
because they get followed by Ghana there
you go and then they become big
youtubers themselves and then usually
after the breakup season waiting for
successful their raywilliamjohnson right
now yeah yup erase Conan on Facebook
videos are always like viral girl yeah
well I mean the ones that I've seen at
least but I'm like he's able to
transition this content over to do you
dabble on Facebook you know a little bit
once I was able to like monetize I was
like I might as well just utilize it you
know that's my dream I can now for Jess
that's my dream for her that she can
provide for you well I the part where
they run away hmm I don't want that yeah
but the part that they surpass your
success hmm I want that hmm oh but your
she's gonna surpass really fast like
that's what I'm saying
oh fast it's crazy how fast I'm gonna
survive I want her to surpass the [ __ ]
is this your girlfriend yeah okay this
she was she on social media before you
the hole okay so you filled her on the
accountant yeah oh my gosh she hated
well she still does hate the spotlight
yeah but I just keep pushing her like
I'm like please become successful please
change for me like why should we market
Disney Princess ya know like be super
successful because I don't want to worry
about like anything you wanted to be
like a makeup gurus I'm like whatever
helps whatever works she open up toys I
don't give a [ __ ] just become successful
she can I come on contribute yeah
contribute or just a she can
I want a freedom what's the chill here I
want a free lay on the beach so I take
care of her really [ __ ] baby yeah
yeah I take care of her really [ __ ]
good because I call it investing yeah
cuz she's gonna remember all the moments
that's our man how romantic is that
she's gonna remember like man he took me
to all these great places and I'm like
that's right girl
now you take me now where's my pet
rabbit I've been asking for pretty cheap
but it's different when somebody gifts
you Adam somebody gives you an animal it
is very different there's no greater
responsibility where did this come from
this I've never heard this one it's an
old fable it's a metaphor to doggy
that's what I'm saying that's a dog gift
isn't it yeah the way the [ __ ] do you
want a rabbit yeah you guys gave me
Brown that was a dog is something bad
he's saying it's been a while since ago
you guys don't care about gifts so it
doesn't matter okay I'm terrible I guess
I don't I don't I'm not a good gift
giver me either
my wife's good at it are you good get
forget gifts oh yeah
you know what I do I provide a great
life for people that's my gift you could
say we you're rocking with your welcome
anytime
good to the matrix and we don't always
looking at cuz he's wear the shades he's
like this these [ __ ] lights are so
[ __ ] with you right now why they've
always been there you know what this
video is about homeboy over here that's
right so Josh tell me about the Netflix
show what happened with a Netflix show
yeah Netflix show we shot season one it
was crazy cuz who actually wasn't
supposed to be for Netflix I don't know
if I'm supposed to talk about that but
whatever we shot it like four years ago
and it was supposed to be for like this
other platform and it I mean the
production value it was like super low
budget man like is Betty I wasn't super
proud of it yeah but then I got a bunch
of foot in the door if you want to get
into that cus for sure and I did I
wanted to do some hosting stuff and so I
was like I was gonna use this for like
practice and stuff not knowing that I
was gonna end up on a platform like
Netflix yeah and then I got the call
literally a week before I was gonna go
on and I was like oh shoot it's crazy
and just to receive criticism like
outside of like
my platform you know from like the world
I guess what that was hatred
oh dude yep Oh relax you said so how did
I even reach you on your and so just
like Twitter I guess they just do you
feel important hey no no no no don't you
think it's kind of a matter I'd feel
important if outside of YouTube people
criticized me well I would cuz that's
how you kind of go viral or whatever
right is when you're getting hatred
people are just criticizing the show and
then people thought that I created the
show not knowing that I was just so how
does that nothing to do with that in my
show you get outraged um a little bit
some people did yeah some people did why
cuz their weed is not a joke to you or
what I don't know do you or just means
there's this cruel they just everybody
just has their own opinion and what they
wanted to see on the show and they
wanted to see more weed and they just
felt like the celebrities weren't
celebrities that's for sure this because
they saw it on Netflix it's expected
this big ol thing and they don't know
the backstory I've like dude this like
probably the budget was smiling on 20k
was a super low I don't know I don't
know but like yeah and then it's so just
those crazy I'm asked a very important
question right now okay
so did they smoke weed before they ate
the food some people did they didn't
want people to do that they want to just
for them to experience the food and get
high for us to go and there's weed in
the food the the whole point of it is
like cooking with cannabis right right
so then you you you do that and then
they taste it taste it so that we would
do a thing called a THC timeout where
they would take time for the the weed to
settle in to settle in and for them
again well I didn't cuz I we were
shooting like three to four episodes a
day so I couldn't yeah what was the best
piece of criticism you read about
yourself worried like that's pretty true
and funny
I I think I said I saw somebody who was
someone who's talking about like my eyes
twitching cuz I was like so nervous I
was like what's up guys like welcome to
cooking on high like Rose my first like
hosting thing would like or election it
only needs up joint for real for real
he stopped twitching your eyes after
that what no dude throughout the whole
season
I haven't got to all the episodes
because like I yeah just like cranes on
myself like it's just
but whatever another producer reviewed
of control yeah you know it been on
YouTube for like I've been six seven
years now edit my own videos I touching
their normal videos no because this just
be in my room do my thing I don't care
yeah I'm comfortable yeah and I can edit
it out I can I don't know do something
to like cover it up but I couldn't you
know what's crazy
Isis sell weed and used to be hella
legal and I would be afraid go to jail
the other day I had an injury on my
ankle right and then I use CBD oil or
anything that's great yeah so I was like
you know what I think I'm gonna go to a
[ __ ] collective and go grab something
so then I was like oh well CBD oil is
not weed right so so I could get it
without the card so I buy it and then
the guys telling me trying to sell me
some gummies and all that and then he's
like do you smoke and I was like
occasionally oh would you be interested
in some you know uh I guess strand where
it's like for pain and stuff and I'm
like oh but I don't have a car and he
goes you don't need one and I said
little you're like yeah he's like it's
like drinking you just need a you just
need a ID I didn't know this no you know
why it's because I've always obtained it
illegally and I like to keep that close
to my heart you know I I miss the
secrecy the culture is gone true
[Music]
upgrading like Denver just passed oh
that's great how does that work so you
people can just do shrooms on the
streets and it's fine I think so but you
know why I realized why they made this
okay guess how much the taxes I wasn't
sent as I much succeed twenty to thirty
percent fairness on any wheat products I
[ __ ] you not yeah the CBD who I had THC
it was THC and CBD mix oil I mean uh the
ointment that I bought right it was like
60 something dollars but after tax and
everything was a hundred something but
all
- all prize do you know if in Denver you
can Truman Drive which would be the
greatest trip of all I just found out
that it got past I don't know exactly
about it
because most of it because DUI if you're
still intoxicated
no matter the substance yeah even
prescription drugs they say you cannot
be yeah because you're under the
influence I've always wanted your shroom
and then go to Disney because people say
that that's pretty dope it's really fun
do you have you ever smoked weed yeah
well not I haven't yeah I tried to I
can't I can't inhale very easily he
doesn't like him what that sounds like
and then you caught them then you were
done for the rest well yes no I keep
posting like a cigar it's more like a I
tried to inhale it I coughed and then I
did edibles and that that was successful
you like edibles no well yeah I hate me
and I it's like a CBD oil / there's some
THC in it and you put it on your tongue
yeah I got that I put it in my tea and
and they're like yeah it helps you kind
of like relax and whatever yeah so I
felt it I mean it only lasts like 10
minutes ish really yeah I didn't put
enough I just I do need a drop in so I
had a CBD drink oh yeah like the I like
lemonade I had one of those and I was
like huh and it was a trip because it
really did call me down yeah yeah it's
physical you could feel you could feel
it but you're mentally alert
why were you uncommon we were about to
get a fight no it was just like I don't
know I'm usually very anxious like I'm
an anxious person yeah you by yo-yo
that's what you do yeah give it all that
tension that you have yeah I'm a very
tense person so drinking mad I was like
really it hasn't affected me like I love
CBD but I just do more for like the
health reasons that I've heard about
like inflammation and yeah that's why
there's new stuff coming out about all
that stuff yeah but yeah I didn't it
didn't like [ __ ] me up or anything it
was just it made me feel just a little
bit lighter and then you can feel how
tense you are like if you can isolate
your body parts you go oh man I've been
like flexing this whole part and then
when you drink
you realize that everything this is how
it's supposed to feel like supposed to
feel like you're kind of floating in
your relaxed alcohol there's old there's
a lot I always feel like I'm like this
and then like you just like remind
she'll be like oh [ __ ] I was like super
tense yeah see I did I took a marijuana
brownie whatever pot brownie is that the
cool kid said yeah so then so then I
went mini-golfing okay oh and it was
actually not fun which I've never lied
I've always had fun mini golfing until I
did pot and then when you ate the you
ate you ate my brownie I was too hot as
paranoid as [ __ ] and I ate a little
corner of a brownie
I just parents [ __ ] about what what do
you get paranoid I was like I will never
be able to write again to [ __ ] do any
do bill if you can't get out of it
you're trapped in this I'm not I won't
be quick I'll be slow I'm being I'm
being very slow right now the lack of
control yes I've had a paranoid trip
before it feels like everyone's looking
at you and you just why are they staring
at me well yeah [ __ ] is going on
everyone's talking about me some people
feel like they're dying
oh yeah that's a that's a panic attack
edibles yeah yeah if you want to know if
I'm high ask me like if you see me do
any marijuana at all ask me if I'm high
and I'll say I'm not high I'm not
[ __ ] high though it didn't work on me
I'm not high and that's what I you know
I'm high as [ __ ] cuz like like you said
like I like to feel like I'm in control
and then I don't want people to [ __ ]
be like wait oh he's [ __ ] [ __ ] up
or whatever
yeah overcompensate for it and I'm just
swearing my high the whole time it's
very annoying
I think what's cool of marijuana for me
is I never ever got paranoid ever in my
life but it feels like when you're about
to like cross over into another realm of
just like [ __ ] it when I get high I like
being in that zone so even if there's 20
people looking at me I'm like [ __ ] it
I'll [ __ ] a bush I'll take my pants off
no no no no I used to smoke a lot in
high school and then randomly a few
years ago where in Vegas I smoked once
and then I just go [ __ ] it and then
we're just I'm just like dragging my
hands along like I feel like I'm like a
Coachella like hipster guy yeah it's
dragging my femurs at work
just like rubbing my hands along the
casino wall this year got a [ __ ]
sunflower headband and selfie with all
the girls and [ __ ] have any of you done
at all yes that is nice bro do you drive
for fun yeah I did it to like edit to
help me out it a sex I hate editor did
you get [ __ ] done like a mother food I
clean my room bro like I was on it dude
I just felt like I just was just ready
to do anything but I was always toxic we
just met and this episode is brought to
you by dude hello my name is Steve green
for adderall it's tight I wrote a whole
[ __ ] I wrote a whole [ __ ] season
of a series of a show on adderall in a
day do you still take it though no no I
started dealing with like depression and
like the cut like the you know like the
calm down that was bad
oh really for me I just highly addictive
I just had dry mouth like a [ __ ]
I didn't come down for anything
I was just drink water because you feel
like you're thirsty the whole time I
liked it but I liked it but I just I
don't know I don't want to get addicted
I started reading about and stuff like
that I told my doctor that I was taking
in stuff and I didn't realize how bad it
is for you like he's like it's like it's
bad for you yeah dude it's the same
basically it's in its limited its jaws
yeah it's the same like basic like when
you chemical compound like when you draw
it up it's the same thing as meth here's
the thing though if you're already
pretty pretty good getting something
done if you do this [ __ ]
you will [ __ ] get it done in three
seconds man it's same and if I take it
it just makes me a normal person there
you go don't take a joke I like being
pretty natural I think the only thing I
do is just coffee love coffee yeah I
like I like being how I am and then
ensure we yeah I just like being how I
am and I feel like that feels good with
like a little enhancement a little bit
and then if I feel weird I try to figure
out self like changing ways so if I'm
feeling sad or like depressed or too
happy or nervous or anxious too happy I
don't know just like convert like you
know when you're not at you're like
equilibrium I like being able to
self-regulate and I try to talk myself
out of that
rather than like oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
anxious oh [ __ ] I could do that yeah but
when when I want like if I'm having a
bad trip I can bring myself to like have
a good trip that's cool but not from the
day-to-day normal [ __ ] oh wow that's
like the opposite yeah so if I'm
freaking out if I'm under your influence
or something I could bring myself to be
like no no I'm having a good time and
then I'll have a great time but I can't
do that if like like if to rest out and
I'm sober I'm like I'm just [ __ ]
stressed out out like it's why I don't
know just do the same thing I just
realized that just do the same thing how
easy could be is so easy I don't know I
guess maybe because my mind is being
influenced by something else I don't
know there's no consciousness stronger
when you're yeah sober yeah no no when
you're yeah your subconscious oh you're
not as present maybe yeah
when they're sober yeah maybe you want
to be present mm-hmm there you go hon
that'll be 900 bucks for the hour
[Laughter]
[Music]